[Musique]
non
la 103e édition de l'open de france de
golf débute ce jeudi à 17 octobre au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
petite particularité cette année à les
français font partie à des favoris nous
les avons entendus en conférence de
presse
mon objectif cette semaine forcément de
de performer au mieux d'essayer de le
prendre comme n'importe quelle semaine
même si forcément c'est difficile de
l'arrêter en france et voilà après c'est
de me concentrer sur le jeu je connais
le parcours ce qui est un avantage
j'essaie de faire un bon open de france
en général le parcours est très
différent des autres années il va être
plus abordable les conditions vont être
plus compliqué donc ça va être un mix de
juin est resté focalisé sur les choses
que je me que je contrôle que je
maîtrise
après je suis dans une bonne dynamique à
mes côtés thomas levet qui a gagné le
tournoi cet open de france vous êtes le
dernier française qu'un français va vous
succéder moi c'est ce que j'espère c'est
que j'ai mis sur les réseaux sociaux
j'espère que cette année quelqu'un va le
faire passer ex anciens vainqueurs
dernier français de l'open de france
vous ferait plaisir ah oui beaucoup de
plaisir et puis surtout il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui se battent pour gagner des
tournois comme ça sur les tournois
internationaux il ya de très très jeune
même des amateurs qui joue le tournoi à
cette semaine et pour eux c'est beaucoup
d'expérience de jouer de profiter de cet
open de france qui a un petit peu
descendu en classement dans l'ordre des
tournois du circuit européen mais mais
ça permet justement aux jeunes
générations de jouer le tournoi et c'est
vraiment le point positif de cet open
[Musique]
paul hermitage le directeur du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
est à mes côtés
paul comment ça se passe cette première
journée de compétition très très très
bien en fait on n'a pas eu une goutte de
pluie ce qui est ce qui est formidable
le parcours les joueurs en plébiscite et
hier et avant-hier dans le lait les
interviews donc on est content ça c'est
notre objectif ça c'est notre rôle c'est
de produire un parcours la hauteur de
l'événement et puis là on est à mi
journée à peu près un petit peu plus de
la mi-journée puis les français jouent
bien au niveau les installations est ce
que vous êtes satisfait oui très parce
que les sponsors a changé 1 je le
rappelle à chênée était le sponsor
principal l'année précédente cette année
c'est amundi qui a repris le relais est
ce que vous êtes satisfait oui oui c'est
différent parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
à notre date depuis 15 ans dans
l'habitude d'avoir le dernier week-end
de juin au premier week-end de juillet
et là on est mi octobre donc ça nous
change au niveau de la physionomie un
peu au niveau 2 des vêtements par
exemple
mais franchement il ya de quoi
amusé et occuper le public qui vient
vous attendez combien de personnes sur
cet événement alors là là je peux pas
vraiment vous dire des chiffres c'est
vrai que ce matin il y avait des gens
devant la porte
on va à huit heures du matin on a des
indicateurs qui sont extrêmement bon
pour le week-end ce qu'il nous faut
vendredi soir c'est un français en tête
nous allons justement rencontrer les
spectateurs qui sont présents ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines m'ont apporté
un peu les français on aime bien venir
au golf national
vraiment tous les ans on est venu ici
pendant la ryder cup
donc monsieur golfeur depuis depuis
entendre qu'on aime bien venir supporter
les équipes est pour la paix dans le
golfe c'est toujours un plaisir
c'est l'occasion aussi de voir des
joueurs n'a pas l'habitude de voir au
pouvoir approcher d'aussi près dans
d'aussi bonnes conditions notamment les
français notamment les français on
essaie de venir tous les ans parce que
c'est quand même l'événement l'événement
golf en france de l'année donc
donc c'est sûr que c'est toujours
sympathique à voir à l'issue de cette
première journée de l'open de france le
sud-africain cozzi et le néo-zélandais
ryan fox sont premiers avec un coup
d'avancé
le premier français benjamin hebert est
dans le top 10 à un coup des leaders jeu
content je fais une bonne journée
aujourd'hui c'est un parcours qui est
difficile on sait je content parce que
j'ai travaillé mon putting en début de
semaine j'ai eu un petit moment
d'entraînement avec un expert du petit
qui s'appelle david orr et ça va
vraiment bien marché on a changé un
petit peu mon putter aussi avec avec
alex d'un come on fit heures et ça a
bien fonctionné donc je suis vraiment
content
[Musique]
vendredi 18 octobre c'est reparti pour
une nouvelle journée de compétition les
températures avoisinent les 15 degrés
mais la principale difficulté
aujourd'hui sera le vent avec des
rafales à près de 50 km heure les
spectateurs sont venus couvert surtout
un bonnet une écharpe et puis un coup
devant sa principale mans et puis de
temps en temps se mettre à l'abri se
protéger pourvu qu'on ait pas d'eau
c'est l'essentiel sur les greens
benjamin hebert le français termine sa
journée à la cinquième place nicolas
colsaerts et jean jeu cozzi ont pris la
tête de la mundi open de france avant le
week end
super content parce que des bustes est
vraiment pas facile ça soufflait fort
là c'est un parcours compliqué à jouer
donc quand les conditions sont pas
faciles s'avérant tous beaucoup plus dur
dernier jour de compétition de cet open
de france 2019 ce dimanche 20 octobre
nicolas colsaerts eux disposent de trois
coups d'avancé avant d'aborder le
dernier tour le golfeur reste le favori
du public
tiens franco belge s'est peut-être
nichols art
on verra on verra il a du mal mais tout
le monde a du mal aujourd'hui des
pronostics qui se sont avérées justes
nicolas colsaerts remporté au trou
numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
en conférence de presse le franco belge
de 36 ans vit ce moment avec sa famille
via son téléphone
c'est énormément de joueurs
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois j'aurais dû
gagner plus souvent comme je l' ai déjà
dit souvent elle fait de gagner chez
vous c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français de leur côté les
français n'ont une fois de plus pas
réussi à dompter ce parcours de
l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française victor perez et
benjamin hebert termine 16e
c'est un parcours que je connais bien
qui me résiste souvent a donc cette
année je suis content parce que j'ai
quand même réussi à faire une bonne
semaine
on les attend évidemment toujours encore
plus haut dans le leaderboard
mais indéniablement c'est une bonne
année pour le golf français sur
l'european tour avec victor perez qui a
la tête là du camp français actuellement
talonnée par benjamin hebert on n'oublie
pas également les jeunes pousses comme
romain langast ou encore michael
lorenzo-vera cette 103e édition de
l'open de france de golf s'achève ici
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
rendez vous l'année prochaine du 2 au 5
juillet à 2
[Musique]